[music]
people of color, residents of the occupied
territories and those who are in the
immediate vicinity of the steel became
hostage hostages
in the aggression of Russia. That is, these are just people who
live in their homes but are forced to either
flee from the war or take on the
whole  the blow of the merciless war machine in the
Russian top
[music]
[music] the
very first arrival on which I left
It was on February 26, we left, it was
incomprehensible You are going You do not understand where
what awaits you and whether
something else will come from above
after us already when we arrived  to the place
in the first place We were engaged in extinguishing
this object and finding out whether there are
familiar people there or
who was there who was not there
[applause]
[music]
and only in 8 months of full-scale
Russian aggression we documented 24
thousand episodes  war crimes are the
deliberate destruction of residential buildings, schools,
kindergartens,
hospitals, churches, are shootings in emotional
corridors of humanitarian aid, are the
abduction of  playing the role of killing and
torturing civilians in the occupied
territories
[music]
and I personally interviewed hundreds of people who
came out of Russian captivity, they did not
tell me the terrible stories of those who
were beaten, who were raped, who were beaten into
wooden boxes,
our state showed the whole world that
it can kill, but you  All of Ukraine,
our spies have shown that
it is impossible to kill Ukraine,
it is a country of
real people, strong, courageous
people who have felt their strength and shown
education, an example of resilience.
in every sense We fight for the
freedom to be an independent state, for the
freedom to be Ukrainians and to develop our
language and culture, and we pay a high price for it
[music]